parler de cette autre rencontre ce lundi
cette fois à montpellier en france les
27 ministres des affaires étrangères se
retrouvent cet après midi bonjour
caroline de camaret avec une question
centrale ils vont examiner la demande
d'adhésion de l'ukraine à l'union
européenne oui demande d'adhésion
express formulée par le président
ukrainien devant le parlement européen
et effectivement lors de ce sommet donc
ce premier sommet puis de sommet de
chefs d'état à la fin du mois on va
tenter de répondre alors d'abord c'est
vrai que l'ukraine à ses débuts en 91
c'était donc s'émanciper de l'urss en 92
elle a fait une première demande
d'adhésion et en 98 les européens ont
freiné ed4 faire parce qu'ils se sont
rendus compte que un certain victor
ianoukovitch qui était pro russe au
pouvoir emprisonner
les opposants politiques ce qui n'était
pas acceptable et puis en plus lui a
refermé la porte à un accord
d'association économique avec l'union
européenne et à partir de là il ya eu la
fameuse révolution
oro meydan qui a porté au pouvoir un pro
européen l'a cette fois ci pour auch
enhco qui lui est assignée et alors ça a
déclenché la fureur de vladimir poutine
en s'en souvient qui a envahi la crimée
le dombass etc alors c'est pour cette
les européens sont très prudents sur ce
dossier géographiquement c'est justifié
cette demande d'adhésion en fait partie
effectivement du sol européen mais il
faut savoir qu'il ya trente cinq
critères à remplir à chacune des
additions qui peuvent prendre 10 20 ans
etc et ça c'est ce qu'on appelle des
additions express 10 ans 1 pour les ex
pays de l'est et puis il ya aussi les
critères de copenhague qui garantit une
démocratie stable alors avec la guerre
ça n'est pas tout à fait le cas avec la
corruption en ukraine ce n'est pas tout
à fait le cas non plus dans la foulée ce
qui est intéressant c'est que la géorgie
et la moldavie les deux autres qui ont
qui ont des conflits gelés avec moscou
et notamment des territoires
séparatistes eh bien ces deux autres
républiques demande aussi une adhésion
express elles ont saisi le moment
l'union européenne fait envie elle est
protectrice defacto et on imagine
d'ailleurs pas que des pays baltes qui
appartenait aussi à l'ex urss et bien
aujourd'hui soit menacée sur leur
territoire sans que les autres européens
puisqu'il ya une clause de défense
réagissent militairement même voilà donc
l'adhésion sera pas pour tout de suite
en tout cas les européens se mobilisent
et ça c'est plutôt inédit en faveur des
réfugiés ukrainien oui tout à fait alors
c'est c'est aussi ce qui est discuté
aujourd'hui à montpellier beaucoup avec
le rappelle qu'il ya déjà un million et
demi d'ukrainiens qui ont pris le chemin
de l'exode josep borrell le chef de la
diplomatie estime qu'il y en aura cinq
millions dans l'est dans les prochaines
semaines puisque ils se dirigent vers
les pays limitrophes la pologne 1
million la hongrie la slovaquie
bizarrement ce sont trois pays du groupe
de visegrad c'est ce fameux groupe qui
refusait tout réfugié lorsqu'il
s'agissait rappelez-vous julien de ceux
qui venaient de syrie et est traversée
via la libye et puis encore par les
frontières extérieures là en
l'occurrence ce sont des réfugiés et
bien européen c'est vrai qu'ils sont un
peu des frères de sang des polonais a
effectivement ils ont des facilités de
visas même avant même que 7,7 cette
guerre éclate et et on voit bien que la
solidarité européenne est très très
forte et en plus moscou qui soi-disant
voulait instaurer des couloirs
humanitaires
et bien tout ça n'est pas sérieux c'est
du cynisme morale et politique a dit
emmanuel macron puisque ce sont pour
l'instant des couloirs humanitaires en
direction de la russie et de la
biélorussie donc de l'ennemi donc ça
n'est pas tout à fait crédible bref les
européens en effet très soudée et très
aux avant-gardes de l'aide pour les
réfugiés est ce qu'on peut s'attendre ce
lundi à montpellier que les européens
adoptent de nouvelles sanctions contre
contre les russes soyons honnêtes
l'invasion russe en ukraine a convaincu
l'union européenne de participer pour la
toute première fois de son histoire déjà
à la livraison d'armes létales à
l'ukraine c'est cette une annonce assez
spectaculaire dans la foulée noter que
l'europe de la défense est en train de
progresser à pas de géant mondial à
toute chose malheur est bon en
l'occurrence le danemark va organiser un
référendum pour s'associer à la
politique de défense européenne qu'il
avait jusque là refusé par opt-out klopp
clause donc 2
de retrait de cette politique est bien
là il est visiblement très intéressée
des pays du nord qui sont plutôt neutre
aussi sont intéressés par l'otan ça fait
évidemment beaucoup bouger les lignes et
le besoin de protection se manifeste et
puis les européens vous l'avez dit ont
lancé de grandes un grand une grande
salve de sanctions notamment via le
système interbancaire souhait swift mais
on peut aller au delà on parle beaucoup
et le président ukrainien demande un
embargo sur le pétrole russe on voit
bien qu'il ya encore de la latitude et
de la marche pour les européens même si
cette sanction les sanctionne énormément
aussi ils prennent le risque d'une crise
aux économiques importantes au niveau de
l'europe mais pour défendre les
ukrainiens merci beaucoup caroline de
camaret vous reviendrez nous voir dès
que la conférence de presse de josep
borrell et de gens ivres